vous avez faim d'action et d'humour avec
la 4Dx découvrez la première publicité
Center pizza il faut arrêter Superfly
formation tortues
[Musique]
un problème avec la violence tu es le
meilleur Ninja Turtles exclusivement au
cinéma vivez-le en 4Dx réservation sur
l'application et sur patte point fr
[Musique]
ce soir maître splinter nous a confié
une mission très importante la cible de
l'autre côté de la rue on doit agir avec
discrétion et ruses pour infiltrer le
monde des humains et récupérer
un paquet de nouilles un paquet
votre motivation
sans crème des fruits des légumes et
range forme un maxi fiesta perso je l'ai
prévenu
deux fois ok Denis tu te charges du
papier toilette RAF tu remplis le
garde-manger et Mickey tu fais le plein
de John food souvenez-vous aucun humain
ne doit nous voir vous vous rappelez
pourquoi les humains sont la vermine
démoniaque de la terre il faut les
éviter il faut pas les saluer ils
adorent massacrer tout ce qu'il leur
ressemble pas interagir avec eux ben
écoutez la vie et je sais que c'est
carrément un préjugé mais c'est ce que
papa nous a appris moi je trouve les
humains plutôt sympa franchement Beyoncé
et les jeux vidéos c'est encore mieux
les pizzaiolo les gamers pizzaiolo les
gamers pizzaiolo qui font du breakdance
bon écoutez on pense tous que les humain
S sont cool mais on a une mission au
boulot au boulot